ja hier auf den straßen in washington
das ist ein rausch der gefühle also die
leute die sind voller euphorie ich muss
dazu sagen wir waren vor hin zu meiner
letzten seite hinter drei blöcke weiter
also kurz vorm weißen haus wir mussten
uns hier her bewegen weil die daten
nicht mehr übermittelt wurden das netz
vollkommen überlastet sowohl am handy
als auch von unserer kamera also da kann
man sich so ungefähr mal vorstellen wie
viele menschen da gerade hinter mir sind
schätzungsweise 7000 menschen etwa auf
diesen wenigen drei blöcken auf der
straße dicht gedrängt und vor allem eins
in einer unglaublich kurzen
geschwindigkeit hat sich das hier
gefühlt als heute morgen war wirklich
noch die ruhe vor dem sturm
man konnte fast die vögel zwitschern
hören und jetzt sind hier 7000 menschen
alle irgendwie bewaffnet mit schildern
mit kappen mit t shirts beiden harris
alle jubeln musik es wird gefeiert also
inzwischen hat man auch bei diesen
ganzen jubel nicht mehr
die rufe nach tampons ort als am anfang
sechstens electric dir was mit die leute
strömen hier auf einer seite nach wie
vor unentwegt hinter mich auf diesen
platz es fühlt sich immer noch es sind
scharen massen an menschen die gerade
hier auflaufen
vor dem weissen haus und diesen sieg
feiern
ja also ausgelassene stimmung dort auf
den straßen wir sind gespannt wie sich
das jetzt noch entwickelt es ist ja noch
relativ früh bei dir das wird zum abend
hin bestimmt noch viel mehr begeistern
also hier kamen gerade wieder so ganze
gruppen mit t shirts bei dan harris und
so an die leute trommeln ja wenn die
einlaufen
also es wirklich eine sehr ausgelassene
stimmung und ich würde mal sagen das
geht bis mindestens heute abend wenn ich
noch die nächsten tage so weiter mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bild schaut euch hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren